I'm gonna start with Peter tell me why
was Einstein interested in this
particular problem and what did he have
to say about it well in some ways the
history of modern physics all the way
back to Descartes and Galileo has been
about unification in fact the story of
the unification of physics is in essence
the story of what we want from our
understanding of the physical world
Descartes thought you could get rid of
all those absurd categories of the
nearest Italians get rid of talking
about fundamental wetness and dryness
and hardness and softness and reduce
everything to just matter hitting matter
locally and Newton said that's all very
well to try to get rid of long distance
forces but what we really need is
something fundamentally different to
mathematical law that connected the
third leg of an ant to the moons of
Jupiter everything every speck of matter
in the world is connected to every other
speck by the same law and that that
would unify things not des cartes
picture by the time you got to Einstein
at the beginning of the 20th century he
had a very different conception of unity
yet again every one of his papers of his
great papers begins by saying not
there's something wrong with experiment
not by saying there's something wrong
with mathematics it's been used in the
theory but by saying there's an
asymmetry in nature in the way we
understand nature that's not present in
nature itself and he said when you look
at a magnet and approaching a coil as
far as the world's concerned there's no
difference between whether you take the
point of view of the magnet or the coil
and we ought to build our physics around
that not on some idea that we have about
which is basic and which is not when he
looked at Luke liquids like water he saw
the conflict between our picture of
matter is made of atoms and that which
is fluid and continuous and he said
that's no good we need to be able to
bring these two together when he looked
at light he said you think of light as
both a particle in certain respects in
the way it behaves in a wave in certain
respects it has to be that we take both
of these into account and begin to think
about unifying them this drove him
throughout his career a sense that he
had to have something that could bring
the world of understanding together to
parallel the symmetries that
we were out there one time somebody
asked him how come professor Einstein
you have no shampoo and only one bar of
soap and he said two kinds of soap
that's one too many he wanted the world
to rip the world of science to reflect
the symmetry of nature itself and the
world that he built the world of that
begins with him to develop quantum
theory and to develop relativity theory
created the conditions under which the
questions that we're going to be talking
about here today spring that is to say
these two foundational pillars that were
built quantum mechanics and gravity have
to come together we can't have a world
in which these two things remain in
contradiction so he said and he devoted
much of the rest of his life to trying
to figure that out somewhat
unsuccessfully from our perspective now
but in a sense that sets up the problem
that we have today which is how do we
join these two pillars that Einstein set
up how do we find the unity that he
searched for all his life but didn't
quite find